[Musique]
paris aujourd'hui
en l'an 2000 la plus belle perspective
du monde des tuileries jusqu'à l'arc de
triomphe n'aura probablement pas changé
[Musique]
le concorde aujourd'hui avions de
l'avenir ne sera-t-il pas remplacés par
une fusée
[Musique]
paris est sans doute la seule grande
capitale certaines de son visage futur
depuis dix ans une planification
générale permet de le prévoir
personne n'oserait toucher aux centres
traditionnels de la ville en dépit des
exigences de la vie moderne
on protège le coeur de paris on
s'efforce de lui rendre son rayonnement
d'antan
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour les seules deux blessés de guerre
le pari classique est classé
d'aujourd'hui restera le même pour nos
petits enfants
[Musique]
le noyau historique et harmonieux de la
capitale exigent que la ville future qui
se dessine aux confins de l'horizon
garde aussi une échelle humaine
[Musique]
le vieux paris
conservera toujours pour le monde entier
c'est charmant inépuisable
[Musique]
empêche de nous
nous avons l'hôtel de ville
des monuments plus récent est critiquée
à l'époque comme le sacré coeur où la
tour eiffel ont été adoptés par paris en
sera-t-il de même pour les réalisations
nouvelles
[Musique]
dans la cité de demain le mur vivant
dans une explosion de couleurs de formes
de matériaux prendra la relève du mur
morne pour effacer des siècles de
grisaille
[Musique]
dans cette perspective le grand public
des transports en commun peut constater
déjà un début d'évolution avec
l'aménagement du nouveau super métro le
rer ou réseau express régional
sur 50 km de saint germain en laye à
boissy-saint-léger
quarante mille passagers à leur pourront
prendre place
traversant paris en un temps record
depuis lutèce en passant par le moyen
âge le grand siècle la révolution
lempire et 150 ans de progrès technique
paris a poursuivi son extension
tentaculaire dans l'île de france
son agglomération va l'envahir en une
seule génération débordant le long de la
marne de l'oise de la scène d'orléans à
rouen avec une population qui aura
doublé et atteindra 20 millions
d'habitants
les problèmes de transport et de
circulation conditionne la vie de paris
il y a pour cela non seulement les
raisons historiques et géographiques
d'une centralisation trop pousser mais
aussi des causes qui résident dans le
tempérament et le caractère
individualiste de ses habitants par tous
les moyens de transport mis à leur
disposition 10 millions de parisiens et
de banlieusards effectué en moyenne 15
millions de déplacements par jour
[Musique]
il dispose d'environ 3 millions de
voitures particulières
sans compter les camions mais la voirie
urbaine
outre la circulation ne permet que le
stationnement de 100000 véhicules malgré
la mise en service de parkings payants
ou non de garages privés ou publics
le problème du stationnement semble très
difficile à résoudre
[Musique]
le bon vieux métro un des systèmes de
transport urbain les mieux conçus du
monde assure le transport de trois
millions et demi de voyageurs par jour
les autobus deux millions et demi et les
lignes de banlieue de la sncf
sept cent mille
[Musique]
la situation est critique seul un
changement radical des habitudes du
rythme et des horaires de travail comme
des loisirs pourrait éviter la lente
paralysie et l'asphyxient de paris dans
son propre trafic
[Musique]
un premier grand effort a été entrepris
avec le transfert des halles qui n'était
pas seulement le ventre de paris mais
dont l'animation jour et nuit
constitué depuis plus d'un siècle en
dépit de tout un des charmes les plus
pittoresques de la capitale
[Applaudissements]
les halles centrales
sauf pour le marché de la viande ont été
installés dans la banlieue sud au marché
d'intérêt national de rungis
il s'étend sur 500 hectares offrant la
possibilité de faire passer le volume du
trafic de 5000 à 11000 tonnes par jour
d'ici 20 ans
[Musique]
une augmentation du rendement de ce
nouveau marché nécessite de nouvelles
méthodes de gestion à rungis
les journées jusqu'à maintenant calme
contrastant avec l'agitation nocturne
doivent être également utilisés en dépit
des habitudes d'une profession qui
répugne à changer ses méthodes de
travail et ses horaires traditionnels
[Musique]
la viande a trouvé à la porte de la
villette au nord de la capitale
son propre marché qui est en voie
d'achèvement
[Musique]
presque un demi million de bovins
sans compter les moutons et les porcs
peuvent passer par la ville est en 1 500
mille tonnes de viande
soixante quinze mille tonnes dab à 65
milles tonnes de volailles gibiers 25
mille tonnes de cuir brut sorte de ce
marché
tout y est traité depuis l'arrivée des
bêtes vivantes jusqu'au morceau fournit
aux détaillants
[Applaudissements]
les anciennes halles les fameux pavillon
de baltard abrite provisoirement des
manifestations diverses marché
d'antiquités foire cirque théâtre pistes
de ski plastifiée entre autres
[Musique]
mais la réfection complète de ce
quartier entre les trois bornes que sont
la fontaine des innocents
la bourse du commerce et l'église
saint-eustache et maintenant décidé
après les discussions longues et
passionné des intéressés officielles et
privées
un projet d'ensemble se dessine trois
niveaux superposés pourrait accueillir
un théâtre lyrique une grande
bibliothèque des installations sportives
y compris une piscine olympique un
centre commercial des bureaux des
habitations des pièces d'eau et des
espaces verts
un nouveau centre de vie de travail de
loisirs
du palais de chaillot édifiée juste
avant la guerre à la maison de l'eau et
rtf de construction plus récentes on
mesure l'évolution accompli pendant un
quart de siècle dans l' architecture
mais jusqu'aux années 60 la rénovation
de paris se limitait à des réalisations
isolé et spécifiques
c'est seulement depuis que des
collectifs de promoteurs d'urbanistes
d'architectes de sociologues et experts
ont pensé conçu planifié des ensembles
cohérents et modernes comme le nouveau
15e arrondissement
ce mini manhattan sur scène destinée
surtout à l'habitation remplacera un
quartier vieillot
[Musique]
pour l'ensemble maine montparnasse doter
bientôt d'une super tour se pose est un
autre problème
il s'agissait d' associer en plein coeur
de paris
le débit quotidien d'une grande gare
avec un centre commercial des bureaux
des logements et des possibilités de
détente
cette tentative choque encore beaucoup
de parisiens nostalgiques du vieux
montarnaud est irritée par l'intrusion
du gigantisme
[Musique]
avec le tout nouveau quartier de la
défense
voué aux affaires il n'y a pas de cas de
conscience situé à l'ouest
en dehors de l'enceinte traditionnelles
de la capitale il suscite plutôt de la
curiosité est aussi un peu d'orgueil
[Musique]
l'énorme chantier de la défense qui se
cristallise autour du plus grand palais
d'exposition du continent le cnit
première réalisation de cet ensemble
préfigure réellement l'avenir
[Musique]
dans cette ville nouvelle
tout sera subordonnée au bon déroulement
du travail et de son environnement
tout y sera systématiquement planifié
une fois terminé le quartier de la
défense comptera vingt mille habitants
et cent mille personnes y travailleront
le jour dans des bureaux couvrant 1
million de mètres carrés de superficie
[Musique]
on
madame 2000 ne risque-t-elle pas d'être
aliéné ou conditionnés par cette
ambiance et cette atmosphère si
différente de celle qu'ont connu ses
parents
non
mais les architectes futuriste ne se
contente plus de leurs projets actuels
qu'il considère déjà dépassé
une tour polyvalente de 750 mètres de
hauteur est envisagée elle sera
l'insolite image de marque de ce pari
bise de la défense l'ère spatiale va
avoir son musée
[Musique]
le parti communiste a confié la
conception de son nouveau siège du
comité central à l'architecte niemeyer
qui a construit brasilia
[Musique]
de nouvelles conceptions également en ce
qui concerne l'infrastructure publique
et sociale
ici la maquette d'un hôpital destiné à
clamart dans la proche banlieue de paris
il satisfait toutes les exigences de la
médecine moderne
[Musique]
cette tour de babel type 21e siècle sera
t-elle le modèle d'un nouveau ministère
de l'éducation nationale à l'emplacement
de l'ancienne prison de la santé
[Musique]
l'imagination créatrice ne connaît pas
de limite ici quelques avants projets
visionnaires le parvis de notre-dame
[Musique]
un pari sous scène
i
un aéroport hypersonique des habitations
cybernétique des cités tour pour trouver
un nouvel espace vital en hauteur
[Musique]
une cité lunaire revenons de
l'imaginaire à la réalité
on retrouve les problèmes concrets qui
domine cette fin de siècle d'abord
centralisation ou décentralisation des
lieux de logement et de travail
cette question est encore plus brûlante
pour paris que pour la plupart des
autres grands centres urbains dans le
monde pour se loger
il faut aller toujours plus loin là où
il y a encore des terrains à bâtir
[Musique]
dans un premier temps l'aménagement de
la région parisienne s'est fait sous la
double contrainte de la poussée
démographique et d'un afflux de
provinciaux l'obligation de bâtir vite
et pour beaucoup a amené un certain type
de site et les villes dortoirs
après avoir paré au plus pressé
les responsables du district ont tiré la
leçon de cette expérience ils ont pu
évaluer les données d'un développement
urbain équilibré pour aider la
population à réduire ces nuisances perte
de temps fatigue inutile complications
de toutes sortes
on a retenu une solution nouvelle la
création de villes satellites autonome
un exemple type et créteil dans le
sud-est parisienne 7000 logements sur
200 hectares les services publics écoles
maisons de la culture artisanat centre
commercial zone industrielle loisirs
sports un grand lac artificiel moyens
d'accès divers pour éviter la monotonie
chaque quartier sera réalisé par un
architecte différents alors que des
créteil vont se multiplier dans la
région parisienne les formes originales
colorées aéré de grands ensembles
s'implante dans la grande banlieue
parisienne le long des axes de
pénétration routières ou ferroviaires
existants ou près
moi
[Musique]
non
là
[Musique]
massy palaiseau très importantes
communes de la région parisienne
illustre bien les problèmes multiples
que pose l'aménagement du district
parisien les créateurs de cette cité
construite à proximité de l'aéroport
d'orly ne pouvait pas prévoir
l'extension du trafic aérien ni
l'apparition des avions à réaction qui
perturbe la vie des habitants
seule une concertation entre les
responsables régionaux des différents
secteurs auraient pu permettre d'éviter
ces inconvénients
[Musique]
la banlieue ouest de paris est depuis
longtemps considérée comme résidentiel
des promoteurs y ont fait surgir des
grands ensembles de standing et par
conséquent de prix élevés
[Musique]
mais la ruée vers l'ouest s'atténue dans
la mesure où la richesse du parc
automobile de ses habitants et l'absence
de transports en commun aggrave les
difficultés d'accès et de circulation
[Musique]
ces inconvénients ne sont ils pas
compensée par une amélioration du mode
de vie
ces résidences permettent après le
travail
une vie en plein air avec toutes les
possibilités d'évasion de loisirs de
sport de récréation
[Musique]
ceux qui auront trente ans en l'an 2000
dispose déjà ici et là d'institutions
pilote adapté au monde moderne
l'expérience de la bibliothèque de
clamart conçu par une équipe
d'instituteurs et de psychologues gérés
par des jeunes aidés par quelques
éducateurs est un bon exemple
d'initiation au monde et à la vie
communautaire futur
[Musique]
c'est ainsi qu'on entreprend de plus en
plus de préparer les petits enfants pour
la vie de demain qui sera polyglotte en
raison de l'intensification des
communications internationales
la première école bilingue actives à
paris n'est qu'un début
mais déjà un succès l'apprentissage
d'une langue étrangère à partir de
quatre ou cinq ans sera bientôt tout à
fait normal
[Musique]
là
sylla
italie
[Musique]
autant de l'ordinateur devenu un
instrument capital de la civilisation
technique
les lycéens apprennent les mathématiques
d'après des méthodes nouvelles alors je
commence par l'addition entre
parenthèses qui a priorité oui c'est ça
alors après je fais une multiplication
pour faire toute la multiplication
d'abord
en effet cet enseignement efficace est
aussi utile pour la culture générale que
pour la plupart des futures activités
professionnelles les laboratoires de
langues approfondie d'une manière rapide
les connaissances de base acquise
auparavant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce romantisme bien parisien de l'ancien
canal saint martin or at il encore une
place dans la ville et dans sa vie
d'après demain
[Musique]
il y a des gens qui contestent
l'existence que nous menions et que nous
préparons pour nos enfants
certains vivent en communauté
[Musique]
d'où pour tous ils partagent les
responsabilités et tous les droits
la vie en complète communauté leur
semble la seule voix le seul moyen pour
échapper à l'étouffement qu'ils
ressentent dans la société de
consommation
[Musique]
le bonjour paris de francis carco
pourrait être paraphraser en adieu paris
des assassins adieu paris des midinettes
défi des mauvais garçons des clochards
et des bals musette
si je te dois d'être poète c'est sur un
air d'accordéon que la publicité
excessive pour la provocation de besoin
et pour la promotion de produits ne
concordent pas avec la quête d'un
nouveau contrat social c'est évident
personne ne conteste qu'il soit
nécessaire que l'appareil de production
des biens comme des services doivent
tourner à plein régime pour améliorer la
condition humaine
mais la surchauffe artificielle de la
machine économique fait craindre à
certains sont des règlements source
d'ennuis pour tous
[Musique]
et
il n'est pas étonnant que la confiance
l'espoir dans l'avenir de beaucoup de
nos contemporains se mêle à la peur et
au désespoir d'une minorité traumatisé
mais qu'est ce que le monde serait
devenu s'il n'y avait pas eu de tout
temps les jérémy et les cassandre pour
évoquer les souffrances et dangers qui
menacent afin de les éviter
comme l'équipe de jeunes artistes qui a
réalisé cette exposition violente et
critique sur des thèmes de notre vie
quotidienne mais qui l'accompagnent et
là tempère aussi des lignes écrites par
paul eluard
je citerai pour commencer les éléments
ta voix à tes yeux et tes mains tes
lèvres
je suis sur terre il serait si tu n'y
étais aussi du tourbillon de la vie et
de ses contradictions ressurgit toujours
la femme préservatrice adaptatrice hier
comme aujourd'hui comme demain
elle s'adapte à son temps et à ses
exigences
[Musique]
l'instant pas
avant de nous voir
[Musique]
l'actualité rejoint la vision du poète
je fais souvent ce rêve étrange et
pénétrant
une femme a connu et que j'aime et qui
m'aiment et guinée chaque fois ni tout à
fait la même ni tout à fait une autre et
même et me comprends
l'environnement intérieur comme celui de
l'extérieur est en pleine évolution
le plastique l'électronique les faits
optique l'habillement préfigure ce que
seront l'esthétique le confort le
comportement futur
[Musique]
comme toujours c'est dans l'art qu'on en
trouve l'image art nouveau où
l'inspiration rejoint la technique et où
la technique semble prendre racine dans
l'inspiration on ne sait plus où est le
réel et l'imaginaire l'humain est à tel
point intégré à la matière que la beauté
formelle d'un corps n'est plus qu'un
élément d'une création totale le
spectacle est beau mais la crainte est
grandissante
serait ce là le symbole de la simulation
de l'être par les choses nous n'en
sommes pas là et le but de l'homme est
justement de sauvegarder sa primauté
sans perdre le contrôle
l'électronique passe dans l'activité
courante sous forme presse-bouton par
exemple avec le self service bancaire
l'utilité et l'efficacité peuvent
prendre ainsi aux yeux de certains un
aspect de gadgets
cependant cette jolie jeune femme est
tout aussi séduite par l'idée d'avoir
son horoscope établi par un cerveau
électronique qu'elle était satisfaite du
bon fonctionnement du guichet banque
ordinateur
[Musique]
il
m
la présence de dieu
attendu
comme attendu
[Applaudissements]
elle est résolument de son effort
sa mère aurait regardé avec effarement
tombé de la machine les feuillets qui
apporte la manne astrologique bottes
hautes et mini jupe elle trouve tout
cela normal et passe le plus
naturellement du monde aux prochains
ordinateurs destinés celui-là aux tests
des connaissances
né parmi les techniques les plus
récentes la jeunesse aime aussi les
créations artistiques mouvante coloré
sonorisé mirage régler comme
miraculeusement par des moyens
cybernétique
mirage analogues aux miroitements des
lumières de la vie nocturne
l'opéra la comédie française les
théâtres soutiendront le prestige de
paris
[Musique]
les drugstores se sont intégrés dans le
paysage gastronomique et commercial de
la ville
ce sont des lieux de rencontre
après une soirée bien parisienne des
restaurants attendront toujours pour
réconforter les 900 villes le bistrot
typique ne verra pas diminuer son
attrait pour une clientèle des plus
composites voir cosmopolite
voilà
ils n'ont pas voté
car
[Musique]
du grand cabaret des champs elysées
jusqu'au boîte de pigalle
la spécialisation la concentration
l'organisation change également le paris
by night sa survie dépendra pour une
grande part du tourisme collecte mais
certains lieux sophistiqué et exemplaire
sauveront toujours la renommée mondiale
du paris des plaisirs goûter des
connaisseurs
[Musique]
à
m
entre temps se prépare surtout pour la
jeunesse d'autres formes de
divertissement qui n'ont plus rien de
traditionnel
[Musique]
c'est
les claques
[Musique]
liberté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le fur
moi
vestri
je
le mépris des voix
[Musique]
le spectacle total est hallucinant sur
scène et dans la salle fini par
confondre acteurs et public dans une
même frénésie
[Musique]
l'oeil omniprésent du grand frère que
prédisait george orwell dans sa vision
déprimante d'une société qui ne
sauvegarde pas son essence humaine nous
sera sûrement épargné mais la caméra et
l'écran de la télévision ne serviront
plus seulement à la seule détente au
foyer tout le long des quais de la seine
la circulation est déjà supervisé par
télévision ce système pratique et
efficace connaîtra une large extension
[Musique]
téléguidage étaient les contrôles
s'effectueront non seulement sur terre
et dans les airs mais aussi dans
l'espace
aujourd'hui déjà parcouru par des
centaines de satellites
le centre national d'études spatiales à
brétigny près de paris pourrait donc
devenir un futur houston français siège
d'un système nerveux pour satellite
européen de télécommunications et
d'observations scientifiques
[Musique]
l'idée artistique se différencie de
l'idée scientifique ou technique par le
fait qu'elle ne nécessite pas de
justification rationnelle
partant de ce raisonnement nicolas
schefer sculpteur et urbaniste hauteurs
de la ville cybernétique créer des
objets pour leur pouvoir d'évocation ils
amplifient leur magie par la combinaison
de la matière de la forme de la couleur
du mouvement de la lumière du son tout
cela est orchestré par un programme
il peut être varié au gré de chacun
ainsi l'acquéreur de ce genre de
réalisation artistique se métamorphose à
son tour en créateur selon la maxime de
nicole haché faire lui même le rôle de
l'artiste n'est plus de créer une oeuvre
mais de créer la création
[Musique]
est ce un fort knox français pour mettre
en lieu sûr en ré devise est ce le
maillon d'une chaîne de fortification
militaire
est ce une centrale nucléaire ou un abri
antiatomique non cette installation
ultramoderne est une protection civile
d'un autre genre c'est une prison au sud
de paris
elle peut recevoir 4000 détenus cette
prison de fleury mérogis et le symbole
matériel de l'esprit de renouveau qui
anime la justice protection de la
société et récupération maximale des
délinquants
[Musique]
le numéro sans frais est demandé aux
parents
le numéro 3400 faire les demander
[Applaudissements]
l'homme seul est un escalier nulle part
l'homme ne le mène et lui demeure
d'inhumaine toutes les portes du palais
[Musique]
dans les réalisations de la technique
moderne
l'automatisation jouera un rôle toujours
plus important devant la ressemblance
des pupitres électronique le profane
peut difficilement deviner dans quel
secteur industriel ou scientifique
il se trouve ici nous sommes dans la
plus récente usine de traitement des
eaux en europe celle de choisy le roi
elle alimente le sud de la région
parisienne à chaque stade de la
purification progressive des eaux
pompées dans la scène correspond une
couleur
[Musique]
là dans de multiples bassins
l'eau est rendu à son image éternelle de
pureté en un va et vient incessant
elle suit son chemin chaque jour plus
important et vital entre pollution et
purification
[Musique]
on
non
[Musique]
encore un pupitre encore un écran
maintenant il s'agit de détruire la
masse toujours plus grande des déchets
de la vie quotidienne d'une grande ville
lusine d'issy les moulineaux en bordure
de paris est l'une des plus modernes du
monde
ces quatre énormes chaudière brûle 24
heures sur 24 et consume chacune 19
tonnes par heure
elles fournissent 60 mille kilowattheure
destinées au réseau électrique de la
capitale
toute cette activité est alimentée par
le carrousel permanent des bennes qui
assurent le ramassage des poubelles
moyens anachronique qui laisse prévoir
d'autres méthodes plus rationnelle et
moins encombrants
[Musique]
l'interpénétration de l'art et de la
technique a été exposé pour la première
fois au début du siècle par marcel
duchamp avec la mise en valeur
artistique de l'objet utilitaire en
utilisant d assemblage de pièces
d'automobile armand dans ce qu'il
appelle ses accumulations en donne une
interprétation actuelle
[Musique]
aspects plus pratiques en matière
automobile
les dernières mini création
préfigure-t-elle la vision des rues de
paris enfin décongestionner il y à
celles qui sont traditionnelles il y a
également des modèles plus originaux ils
permettent une vue panoramique et laisse
une place suffisante pour les bagages
[Musique]
on peut voir encore des prototypes
électriques qui présente l'avantagé
d'éviter la pollution de l'air leur
développement pourrait modifier le
visage de certains quartiers
interdiction est en fait à tout autre
modèle d'y pénétrer et d'y stationner on
peut même prévoir un parc de ses
voitures pour l'utilisation publique en
self-service payable par jetant à
l'autre bout de l'échelle les gros
monstre roulants vont peupler de plus en
plus les routes pour le transport des
marchandises
[Musique]
pour le transport interurbain des
solutions nouvelles comme le tueur
vautrin seront bientôt mises en
application
un système parallèle l'aérotrain lui
promet une réelle révolution glissant
sur un coussin d'air il pourra atteindre
les vitesses des avions à hélice et
amener ses passagers au coeur même des
agglomérations actuellement au stade des
essais il donne déjà des résultats très
convaincants les américains s'y
intéresse
la première ligne de l'aéro fin à métro
reliant à 20 minutes de paris et déjà on
pense à relier paris à lyon de la même
façon
[Musique]
ainsi se réduisent dans le temps les
distances entre fils pays et continents
orly et le bourget ne suffisent plus à
l'époque supersonique
un nouvel aéroport géant verra le jour
d'ici quelques années
a roissy au nord de paris
[Musique]
pour le voyageur de demain quelle sera
l'impression dominante qu'il ramènera
chez lui de la ville lumière
si certains signes précurseurs ne
trompent pas l'optimisme et la confiance
en ce qui concerne l'avenir de paris
prévaudront car le génie séculaire de la
capitale française a fait sienne la
phrase du physicien américain dennis
gabor
nous ne pouvons pas cessé d'inventer
car nous sommes à cheval sur un tigre
[Musique]
m